I like being healthy.
When I am healthy, I feel good.
I am in a better mood, and I have more energy.
I do many things to stay healthy.
I like to be active and move my body.
I run, swim, and ride my bike.
I take walks with my big brother, Bill, and our dog, Wilbur.
I like to play sports.
Soccer is my favorite game.
I also take hikes in the woods with my family.
I like television, but I don't watch it for hours.
I like computer games, but I don't play them for hours.
I get up and move around.
Eating well gives me energy.
I eat a good breakfast.
If I skip breakfast, I don't think very well.
I eat a good lunch at school.
Peanut butter and jelly is my favorite sandwich.
I drink lots of milk and water.
My favorite food is pizza.
I also like healthy foods such as apples, carrots, chicken, and yogurt.
I get plenty of rest.
I go to bed early on school days.
And I get up earlier on school days.
My dad says I need 11 to 12 hours of sleep each day because I am growing.
I keep my body clean to stay healthy.
I wash my hands before eating and after going to the restroom.
Washing keeps germs from getting into my body.
I brush my teeth three times a day.
Brushing kills germs that cause cavities.
I also take baths and showers.
And I brush my hair to keep it healthy.
I have many kinds of feelings.
Some are happy, and some are sad.
Laughing makes me feel better.
When I have sad feelings, I feel better when I talk about them with Bill, Mom, or Dad.
Sometimes I like quiet time.
When I do, I watch my tropical fish.
I imagine that I am floating through water just like my pet fish.